[Music]
my name is Chris Lattimer I'm one of the
product managers that works on api's and
API management for Google so I'm part of
the team that runs the Apogee platform
and I've been working on api's for for a
really long time in fact when I first
started off you know looking at API so
it was in the context of
service-oriented architecture and we
were always having conversations about
things like you know should we use soap
should we use rest which one you know
it's better for enterprises and at the
time the feeling was you know soap was
sort of this enterprise technology and
rest was more something for the
Facebook's and Twitter's of the world
this kind of novel technology that that
really wasn't Enterprise ready and so
it's it's interesting to see the changes
that have happened over the last 10 or
so years because now api's are
everywhere you know we have you can't
really go more than five or ten minutes
over the course of a day without using
some type of API anytime you pick up
your phone it's probably making an API
call so if you check your social media
today API calls if you are checking in
for your flight to go home if you're not
a local
that's probably an API call do things
like purchase something online again
another API call and so it should come
as absolutely no surprise that with all
of these critical things that are
running on api's for our organization's
api's needs security and normally the
type of picture that we think of is
something like this so we don't want to
have our organization be on the front
page of Google News saying yet another
data breaches happen and now we're
responsible for taking this information
that our customers have trusted us with
and accidentally leaked it out so that
hackers now have access to our passwords
and our personal information and those
type of things and the natural
inclination that we typically have is to
do something like this to lock up all of
our data how can we take our data and
our API is and make them as secure as
possible so absolutely nobody can get
access to them but the problem is if
that's our approach to API security and
all of a sudden we lock things down so
much that we can't actually
actually use them we're gonna miss out
on all the value of api's and so we're
trying to actually build out API
security locking things down isn't the
hard part it would be easy enough for us
just to not build an API and that's the
most secure API of all but trying to
foster innovation allowing the people
who can build really interesting things
with our API s and not putting in place
really heavyweight bottlenecks and
unnecessary delays while keeping our API
secure is a much much harder problem for
us to solve and that's what we're going
to talk about here today in this session
so the way that we the way that we put
this talk together is I went and I spent
a lot of time so in my role I spent a
lot of time with customers and I get a
chance to talk with organisations from
you know all around the country all
around the world and I like to sort of
ask them what sort of things they're
concerned about and so what we did is we
we started off by looking at specific
customer examples and how those
customers are addressing their security
needs so we'll start off with a pretty
basic one so we have a lot of retail
customers that we work with at Apogee
and a lot of times they'll have api's
like this these are things like like
store locations and hours so they're not
we're not looking at sensitive
information I mean we want people to
know when our stores are open we want
people to be able to find our store
location so they can come to the stores
when they're open to do purchasing with
us but at the same time it's important
information so we probably have these
type of api's attached to our mobile app
we do want to make sure that people you
know that this API does remain secured
so we don't so that people can actually
use it so what type of things do we have
to be concerned about with an API that's
this like this no sensitive information
but yet relatively important well I know
that in a security talk I've learned
I've done a number of security talks
over the years and one of the things
that I've noticed is that if I don't
mention TLS like it's the very first
thing and yeah I've got some security
people in the audience you get very
service that I didn't mention TLS though
so I'm gonna go ahead and get that out
of the way at the beginning that that
there are some basic things that we want
to do at this point TLS is just sort of
implied that we're always going to put
TLS on top of our our api's so now that
that's out of the way the other things
we have to think about one of the one
customer that I talked with he put it
best he said every time I I on board a
new application I just on boarded a new
potential source of DDoS attack and that
doesn't necessarily mean that people are
you know intentionally ddossing but
somebody could do something incorrectly
they could build an app that all of a
sudden just has more traffic than they
were anticipating and all of a sudden
before you know you have floods of
traffic that are coming into this API
and they end up inadvertently taking it
down and again with something like like
a store locator that means that if
somebody is on your mobile app and
they're trying to get access to your
store or find the closest store suddenly
that customer can can no longer actually
come into the store so we have to think
about things like even with this API
that we want people to have access to we
want them to be able to use it how can
we allow them to use it in a way that
doesn't introduce unnecessary risk
so traditionally our approach to this
type of problem was to enforce some type
of heavyweight governance so before I
joined Apogee before we required by
Google I spent a lot of time working for
a large insurance company in our
approach whenever we wanted to sort of
share data was very much a matter of
picking up the phone or sending an email
saying hey I know you have a service I'd
like to use this in my application and
usually the response was something like
great let's sit down when can we get
together and you can fill out this
hundred question questionnaire about
everything you're going to do with my
data and then we'll understand your
business justification and then we'll
decide if we're going to give you access
or not and over the course of weeks of
getting together and sort of reviewing
and security reviews ultimately you
would get access to the API and for no
very good reason we ended up delaying
our ability to actually get something
out the door so a much better approach
of this is just to enforce traffic
management
there's nothing sensitive about this
information it's just store locations
and hours so
what if we could give access to anyone
who wanted it either within our
organization or outside depending on the
API you're working with and say you can
have access to it automatically will
give you access to this API however
we're gonna limit that access so if you
wanted to make more than say 100 calls
an hour or a thousand calls an hour or
whatever is appropriate we're just going
to start throttling that traffic and
we're not going to give you access so we
don't do worry about the floods of
traffic coming in and inadvertently
doing a denial of service and we can
also open up this API so more people can
use it the other traditional approach
that we would see is something like a
service registry and in this sense I'm
not talking about sort of the service
registries than to come along recently
in a micro services based architecture
I'm talking about sort of the the
old-school service web service
repositories and registries and those
type of things where we would try to
keep track of ok who has access to this
API and we'll sort of note down you know
who might be the potential source of
floods of traffic that are coming in how
much better approaches to automate that
so with with platforms that the API
management platforms usually we can do
things like issue API keys and so if we
wanted to be able to look and see
exactly who's making which calls and how
much Tropics coming in API keys provide
us a great way of doing that now we have
an identifier we can use to track our
traffic that's coming through and to
enforce those quotas so we know that as
an API call comes in it has a key this
is the app this is what the apps
entitled to and we'll start throttling
those things right away the other thing
we have to be aware of our content-based
attacks so even though this particular
API doesn't intentionally expose
sensitive data as somebody may try to
get around that and they may try to send
and request that the API is not
expecting maybe they're doing things
like sequel injection attacks or
cross-site scripting and so we want to
be able to protect against those those
miscreants that are trying to send a
negative you know attacks into our API
so this is usually where we start to
think about the capabilities of an API
gateway and how we can use an API
gateway to intercept those calls and to
actually enforce rules that will protect
against content-based attacks and even
though I don't want to make this a
commercial about Appaji just so happens
that Google has a platform called Appaji
that solves all these security problems
and again
if you want to talk about aperture you
have more questions about your API s and
API security happy to dive into those
details and again these are all customer
examples that we've that we've talked to
and worked with as we put this talk
together so the next the next API that
we talked with so this is actually a an
insurance company and one of the one of
the challenges with with insurance is
that it's a highly regulated business
and so in in this particular example
what we had is this insurance company
they have a product that they work with
partners so if you're a Delta Airlines
or Southwest Airlines and you want to
offer travel insurance
you can't just offer your own product
there are regulations about who can sell
insurance in any given state and so this
insurance company that we were working
with offered a travel insurance product
that these partners could use and so we
were talking with them about the
security concerns that they had so one
of the first things that they were
worried about is compliance with
industry regulations so they they
basically said when we're working with a
Delta Airlines or some really large
company they can of course dedicate the
six months required to go through all of
these formal approval processes we can
put in place the controls we need to
make sure that we're complying with with
all the insurance regulations but when
we look at the travel industry as a
whole there's a whole sort of niche
market so we have anybody here from
India seriously
nobody at all oh okay okay so I work
with I work with a lot of people from
India and I've noticed that they they
there are special dedicated travel sites
that are just for trips to India it's
finding like cheap trips to India the
best times to go and and they offer sort
of you know ways to buy this insurance
but these are very small travel sites
there and they're not on par with the
Travelocity or in Orbitz or Delta
Airlines and these smaller companies
they can't invest the same amount of
time and effort and there are too many
of them out there for the insurance
company to actually go and sort of
invest that time as well so they said
we'd like to reach these
these smaller companies but you know
we're should have been in a quandary
here around exactly how we're going to
do that we have to comply with
regulations so how can we how can we
help so the traditional approach was we
just wouldn't we would just work with
the companies who could afford to spend
the time with us to put together you
know a tiger team that's going to go
through and six months later of meetings
and compliance and auditors will feel
confident that they can sell our our
products and others can so what they
found was they can actually use they can
productize api is in such a way that
they can offer them in a self-service
way to these smaller companies so where
as a large company in order to do things
like actually sell up sell an insurance
product you didn't have the same
regulations just to get a quote on an
insurance product so they said what if
what if we could take our api or our
partner api and we could productize that
in such a way that we offer in a
self-service automated fashion anybody
can come and offer a quote and we'll do
a revenue share model with them so that
we can comply with regulations we'll be
the ones that are actually selling the
product not the partner but we can offer
them a way to still comply with
regulations and in doing so what they
what they ended up doing was a it would
enforce fine grained access control so
depending on who you are and who we were
that what's coming into their API
program they could say we're only going
to let you see and get access to these
very specific pieces of our API so we
can still foster the innovation that
we're after but we're only going to give
the full ability to actually sell an
insurance product to our big partners
who are willing to go through this
process with us and when it came to
actually enforcing this at the runtime
perspective what they do is they say
well great when we when somebody signs
up we're going to give you credentials
and you'll use those credentials to
obtain an OAuth token so when an OAuth
token comes in we're going to look and
we're going to say which products do you
have access to do you have access to the
ability to sell the insurance product or
just to get a quote on the insurance
product and so in this way they were
able to take an existing API that they
had built out for their partners and
they were able to repurpose it in such a
that they can now support a tremendous
more a tremendously larger number of
partners now one of the last ones that
we'll talk about here so I was working
with with a large Hospital chain and so
they probably have one of the more
interesting interesting api's that I've
come across so what they've done is they
have wired up their their ICU so you
know they have very very sick patients
that are coming in they've got a lot of
sensors and sort of information that's
constantly flowing back from from the
ICU they've got all the patient's
medical data and they're taking that in
they're building out sort of a risk
assessment so every day if you're a
physician at this hospital and you have
a patient in the ICU it's gonna tell you
here are the patients that are sort of
in the most critical state and here are
the things that we've seen that have
sort of it all led to you know either
either death or negative outcomes that
we should be aware of and here's sort of
a treatment plan and so you can imagine
in this particular case you're dealing
with HIPAA compliant data you're dealing
with you know very sensitive PII data of
course that's coming through and as a
result they had some really major
security concerns so what can what what
should this particular organization be
concerned about well this was by far in
a way their their biggest concern when
you're dealing with HIPAA there are real
legal criminal consequences that you can
run into if all of a sudden you take
take a patient's information in fact one
of the one of the hospitals that that
they run they ended up having some
celebrities coming in and all of a
sudden you had sort of people that
wanted to you know take a sneak peek at
their at their medical records and ended
up finding some people actually in here
so we wanted to make sure nobody ended
up here for no good reason and so one of
the things I want to make sure to
mention during this talk is that
sometimes this approach is absolutely
okay I mean there are going to be times
when we do have incredibly sensitive
information that we're working with and
it's going to be information that
absolutely does have to be locked down
it's not something we can take lightly
that we can allow you know just anybody
to get access to and so I don't want you
walking away from this talk thinking you
know this this guy doesn't understand
our security we're in the financial
industry and we've got you know very we
got people's bank accounts so we need to
do this absolutely it's really more a
matter of one of the key takeaways here
is that it's really a matter of looking
at the api's understanding of the
threats understanding how we can get the
API out as much as possible and
recognizing that sometimes we don't want
it out at all so in this case what they
had to figure out who actually
authorized to access patient data so in
this case it was very clear that they
had depending on on the patient's you
were assigned as a physician they wanted
to make sure you would only see the
information for you know for your
patients and so as a result we had to
have a way for these these doctors and
nurses and other other caregivers to
authenticate and so you know
traditionally one of the problems we
faced and especially in sort of the the
web space is direct user authentication
and we've seen sort of over the years
we've done single sign-on type solutions
and things like that you know home hold
products are sort of sprung up to solve
the SSO problem and so in an API for
from an API perspective we have a
similar construct with a delegated
identity and user authorization so a lot
of times this will be things like open
ID connect where we can now allow users
to sign in without ever exposing our
passwords and our credentials to that
application we can use Open ID Connect
and obtain an OAuth token so this is
often what we would call it three-legged
OAuth where somebody will sign in if
you've seen things like sign-in with
Google or signing with Facebook a lot of
organizations are building their own
sign-in with our platform and then using
those in conjunction with API management
to send in the Open ID Connect request
get back the response and then exchange
that for an access token and now what we
can do is we can identify the end user
that's making these API calls and we can
do fine-grained access control checks to
make sure that only the physicians and
other care givers that should have
access to this particular
information have access one of the other
things that they had to think about was
auditing and so they wanted to be able
to keep track of who looked at a
patient's data so again when we're
looking at not just from the standpoint
of you know people trying to hack into
this account but just from a a auditing
and compliance requirement standpoint a
lot of times they would have you know
specific samplings that they would have
to do so they had to go back and prove
you built this API and over the course
of the last year let's pick a specific
patient and anonymize of course and
let's look at who actually made a
request and to get this particular
patient's data and so what they had to
do is they had to put in place audit
logging and so we could go back and we
could then look and say okay great for
this particular patient who has looked
and let's make sure that they have
access to have have looked at that they
were authorized to look at that patients
data so even with all of these
capabilities that we've talked about we
can still end up with cases where
attackers find away and so to talk about
that I want to invite up my colleague
Matt Bloomberg to talk a little bit
about how we would address those thanks
Chris good morning everybody so my name
is Matt Bloomberg and I'm a product
manager focus on API security at Apogee
and it's Chris talked about it you know
API abuse is becoming much more common
and is predicted to be the most common
attack vector in the enterprise space in
the next few years and I'm going to talk
about some of the features that we offer
to help you protect your api's from
abuse so just with the raise of hands
how many people currently expose api's
through a web app it's about three
quarters and how many are exposing api's
through a mobile app okay about the same
number so over the past couple years
we've seen a significant growth in
public facing API s which is a very very
powerful tool that will help you kind of
transform your business but it
definitely comes with the responsibility
to protect those api's and as much as
the security tools out there
they are great sometimes abuse can
become much more of a concern so in the
enterprise space customers typically
take a multi layer approach and they
typically deploy a web application
firewall and that's does a relatively
good job for web protecting from DDoS
and sequel injection these types of
attacks but they fail to handle the API
specific attacks which is where Apogee
sense comes in so sense leverages API
constructs such as API keys and access
tokens in the context of the workflow to
help identify behavior which is passed
the layer so when we analyze information
such as the user agent an API key and
look at the volume of that traffic with
other attributes over a period of time
we're able to detect API abuse and bot
traffic that WAAFs are not able to
detect so I'm gonna talk for a minute
about how Appaji sense works so we offer
what we call a closed loop protection so
this means that we're able to analyze
all of the api's all of the API traffic
as it streams across your proxies and
we'll collect this data and run it
through our analysis engine which
detects anomalies and abuse and then our
sense console offers insights about what
type of traffic is observing and allows
you to review that traffic and take
action on it including blocking it or
flogging it we'll talk about that in a
minute so I'm gonna walk you through
what a common attack may look like for
many customers there's an expectation of
where they operate their business where
traffic should be coming from so maybe
you have some your selling products
online maybe you're a domestic airline
but you typically know where traffic
should be coming from or definitely
where it should not be coming from and
at a glance here you can see that with
the world map is covered in higher than
normal traffic from all over the world
so many countries there may be you not
be allowed to conduct business but
you're seeing a significant amount of
traffic and in the top corner you can
see that the bot traffic has increased
by nearly 30 percent in the in the near
term so clearly there's an attack going
on in this case so as we dive deeper to
investigate what's what's going on we
can start by reviewing the API abuse in
the detection report tool so this this
is where sense analyzes and unless you
act on behaviors that we can see that
that exceed up thresholds that are said
in the product so for example there's a
Brut guesser
rule which in this case was violated
more than thirty five hundred times
thirty five hundred different bots
resulting in millions of malicious API
calls there's a full list of the rules
here that you can see of and the number
of bots that are exceeding those those
thresholds so this is this is gives you
an overview of the different types of
protection that are offered through the
sentence product so in the previous
slide I showed an example of the brute
guess or policy being violated and you
see higher than normal traffic that
results in errors over a period of time
so that may be someone trying to attempt
to login or someone in another examples
the content scraper rule where a very
common attack used to scrape products
and pricing data so if you have mobile
apps for shopping
those api's maybe or web web apps for
the same use case those may be scraped
for pricing product information or again
like log and api's and these types of
things so we have these various
thresholds and sets of rules that offer
protection for those types of attacks so
if we kind of go back to the attack we
can see that all of the API calls we're
going after the login URI endpoint here
so you can see that the highest value
attacks such as purchasing payments
loyalty programs gift cards and login
are the most commonly abused and require
the the highest level of protection
using tools such as cents if we drill
down on the specific IP address to
investigate further we can also see that
most of the calls in this case all of
them were resulting in four ones and 403
s meaning unauthorized access so this is
what triggered the rule in this
particular case so after review I think
we have enough information to make a
decision to block this traffic so Apogee
sense offers you the ability to block
flag allow block or flag the API traffic
so flagging would allow you to add
custom metadata to the headers which may
enable you to configure a honeypot or
other system to deal with the traffic
you're also allowed to block it at this
point to prevent that that IP from being
able to continue making API calls or
maybe you're running a flash sale or
some other
area where you'd explicitly want to
allow this type of traffic but that's
that's in your control so as we can see
here once we took action the malicious
traffic stopped and we're constantly
working on adding new methods of
detection across our API products Google
is making a very large investment in
security as you may have seen from other
sessions at next and in Apogee it's no
different we're making a very large
investment working with collaborating
across teams with the broader security
teams to take the best security features
machine learning and automation from
Google's products and integrate that
into the future Apogee API products in
the security area as well as other
functionality
[Music]